as school girls before going into hiding
from the Nazis and Frank and her sister
Margot maintained a penpal relationship
with Juanita and Betty Wagner of Iowa
that correspondence is a subject of
Susan Goldman rubens new book searching
for Anne Frank the program is an hour
and 15 minutes well I want to thank
Linda first of all for inviting me here
this is just marvelous I told her this
is not like an ordinary day of writing
it's been like a party all day and let
to see all of you I thank you so many of
you for coming out tonight I was going
to say on the terribly hot night but
it's so chilly in here maybe it came in
to cool off but anyway I'm very glad to
see you and glad to have this
opportunity to talk to you about my new
book it's interesting to have this talk
right here in San Bernardino at your
really marvelous public library I had a
tour of the library before it it's
wonderful really wonder if I belonged to
about eight or ten libraries I'm not
going to tell you about my overdue fines
thats say that for the questions and
answers I won't give you an answer not
an honest one but i really love
libraries and when i was a little girl
growing up every friday i would walk by
myself to the library and take home
books it just meant so much to me in
those days there was a children's
library and an adult's library and at a
certain age I had read all the books I
wanted to read in the children's library
and as a special privilege they let me
move on to the adult section I can't
tell you what a thrill that was so I
still love being in the library and I'm
very happy to be here one of the people
I wrote about in this book lived in
redland her name was Juanita Wagner
Hilton I don't know if any of you knew
her but she's the one who chose and
Frank as a pen pal from a list of Dutch
kids not knowing who she was I'll be
telling you more about that
her son Robert still lives in redland
and her granddaughter teaches at more
middle school do any of you know that
school more oh great I haven't visited
the school but I met Christine and this
book is especially meaningful to her
because it's about her grandmother and
her grandmother's picture is on the
cover and she's going to be sharing it
with her seventh-grade students recently
in recent years for me I've become very
interested in writing nonfiction for
young people especially and every
subject I pic i must say comes from my
heart else i wouldn't do it because a
book like this takes a couple of years
and it's truly a labor of love and i do
the research and writing as well as the
photo research that is i pick all the
pictures myself and as an artist or as a
former studio artist with an art
background i feel very strongly about
what pictures might best tell the story
and i just never give up any of my
editors will tell you that so i wanted
to focus on subjects that are really
important to me that I think that you
might enjoy reading about two and two
main areas of interest for me have been
art just the pleasure of painting and
looking at art and looking at sculpture
looking at architecture and where do
these creative ideas come from and
hoping that young people will feel
inspired to work at their own art and
look at art and another area that's been
very important for me as a Jewish woman
is the subject of Jewish history and in
particular a period that were was very
dark called the Holocaust and I couldn't
even face reading about this subject
until just a few years ago I couldn't
bear it it was too hideous and then I
thought I've got to and I've got to tell
some of the stories that survivors
perhaps can tell on their own
and this has just led me into the most
amazing subjects and amazing friendships
along the way I started going to the
Simon Wiesenthal Center Museum of
Tolerance in Los Angeles have any of you
ever visited if you haven't no I'm glad
you have I hope you will go because my
two good friends there a dark line who's
the director of the library and pharma
more who was the archivist introduced me
to an exhibit and when I saw it I
thought oh my goodness this is something
belongs in a book they took me to see an
exhibit of a pen pal correspondence
between Anne and Margot Frank and two
girls their ages back in nineteen forty
who lived in iowa and what happened was
that the girls in Iowa wrote to the
girls in Amsterdam and Anne and her
sister Margo wrote back in English and
these are the only letters in existence
known to have been written by an in
English and her sister Margo and I just
couldn't get over it and I thought this
is something that I have to find out
more about who were these Iowa girls and
how do they happen to know about the
Frank girls and one thing led to another
and that's why I use the title searching
because it the whole process has been a
search to find out more about the
sisters in Iowa to find out more about
who and Frank really was and her sister
Margo so I did this book in association
in partnership with the Simon Wiesenthal
Center and they helped open doors for me
when I do a book I like to do what is
called primary research that means after
I do a lot of reading to get me started
I want to meet people I want to go to
the places I'm writing about it's not
always easy but I feel I can't properly
know what I'm writing about until I do
that so when it came to working on this
book searching for Anne Frank letters
from amsterdam to iowa i felt i had to
go to amsterdam now I went to the end
house and I had been there once before
but given the research I did before I
went I saw those rooms with new eyes and
having spoken to the heads of
departments there who gave me more
insight information it was just amazing
heartbreaking but amazing I also wanted
to meet people who had known and Frank
and this wasn't easy some of the friends
she had her true friends are our kind of
reticent about coming forward they don't
want to be publicized their friendship
the real friends but I was very
fortunate to meet her best friend during
that last year at the Jewish high school
and it was a lucky break for me I had
done a book published by Abrams my
publisher for an exhibit on Vincent van
Gogh and Paul Gauguin who spent eight
crazy weeks together in the South of
France painting and I called my book the
yellow house Vincent van Gogh and Paul
Gauguin's side by side and I did this
for young people in conjunction with an
art show that originated at the Chicago
Art Institute and wouldn't you know that
right while I was in Amsterdam that show
had traveled to the Amsterdam Museum and
when Anne's friend knew that I was the
author of the book well then she agreed
to meet with me oh and it was wonderful
because she set me straight she said
these are the people who really knew Ann
this is what it really was like another
person I met was one of Anne's
classmates at montessori school and she
took me to the school and we went into
the classroom and I it looks just the
way it did so many years ago and she
showed me where they used to go for ice
cream after school and she showed me
where the Frank family lived their
apartment nearby so this was wonderful
but having grown up in New York and the
blancs I felt I knew more about
Amsterdam than I did Iowa I had never
seen a cow when I was growing up and it
amazed me the first time I ever visited
a farm so I also wanted to go to
Danville Iowa and in 1940 when the girls
exchanged letters
population in Danville was 309 so you
can see what a contrast and as an wrote
in her letter I'll read to you in a
minute the population in Amsterdam was
800,000 so very different city girls
farm girls I thought how did these kids
get together that to me was an
interesting story the theme of the
contrast of what was going on in Iowa
and an Amsterdam during the years of
World War two so i met betty wagner very
sadly whiny to passed away just when I
was starting this book but her sister
Betty is alive and well and lives in
Burbank California and we became friends
and she just shared all her family
photos with me and her immense are open
doors cuz I don't know if you they don't
go for strangers real well so without
Freddie I don't think people would have
talked to me that readily and one of
Juanita's sons went with us and his wife
because he wanted to see where his mama
grown up he is to think anne frank was
just her friend who lived down the
street he didn't realize who she really
was and i want to just mention that to
me the story of the letters was a
suspense story in itself because Betty
and Juanita had no idea who their pen
pals were until nineteen fifty-six
imagine they exchanged letters in 1940
and in a minute I'll give you a sneak
preview of some of the pictures in the
book that helped bring it to life and
Betty heard over the radio in 1956 a
review of a hit play on Broadway called
The Diary of Anne Frank and she said in
an instant she knew it was her Anne
Frank Sheeran to the bookstore and sure
enough the picture on the cover was
almost identical to the one and it sent
her sister I still get shivers when I
think of it so that the whole saga of
those letters kept in a shoebox going
from the farm then out to California it
just a miracle that the sisters
whatever reason held on to those letters
and those photos well right now I
thought I would give you a sneak preview
of the book the book has about a hundred
photos many of them of Anne and Margot
have never before been published I can't
begin to tell you what I went through to
get these pictures I may look small but
I am tough I'm relentless and I just
felt certain pictures had to be in the
book because they hadn't been seen
before and they rounded out my
understanding of who an really was you
know we know the diary I hope that all
of you have read it and if you haven't
you'll go back and reread it as I did or
read the stage play that was based on it
but Anne was a most remarkable talented
writer but as a girl she was just a
fun-loving girl and her father and
mother thought of her older sister
Margot as the bright one as the good
student and even ants teachers thought
she was too talkative in class she
wouldn't shut up she wouldn't hold still
she was crazy about boys and clothes and
ice cream and ping pong nobody guessed
the depth of her talent and her ability
and her own father said when he read the
diary when he brought himself to read
the diary after the war I didn't know my
own daughter until now so this was also
what I wanted to bring out in my book
the other facets of the Anne Frank we
know through the diary with my able
assistant Linda we're going to show you
a sneak preview this first picture is of
juanita Wagner Juanita Jane Wagner this
is a picture taken when she was about 11
years old when she had just chosen Ann's
name from a list of possible pen pals
the next picture is of her teacher Miss
birdy Matthews doesn't she look like a
Miss birdy Matthews she never married
she stayed in Danville but this woman
back in the 30s
and even a beginning of world war one
had a remarkable curiosity about the
world beyond Iowa and she loved her town
and she loved her family and lived in
that same house all her life but she was
very curious about the outside world and
wanted her students to be interested in
the world beyond their little American
town so she thought up this program of
what she called my program of
international correspondence and this
was back in nineteen thirty nine it was
remarkable and she either met Ann's
teacher from montessori in Amsterdam or
miss birdie would take graduate courses
at Columbia University in New York
during the summer and she might have met
Ann's teachers there were not sure I
went through all the archives I went
through boxes of Miss birdies materials
that are in the State Historical Society
of Iowa but we don't know for sure but
she set up this program and the teachers
as teachers do exchange names of
students and one knee to happen to pick
the name and Frank now Juanita wrote to
an and then Anne wrote back and in our
book we decided it was important to
reproduce an actual picture of the whole
letter and as my able assistant shows
you these next images I'm just going to
read the letter that Anne Frank wrote to
Juanita dear Juanita I did receive your
letter and want to answer you as quick
as possible I must mention that Ann's
father otto new English Charles Dickens
was one of his favorite authors and he
had lived in New York at Heidelberg
University one of his best friends was
the son of the owner of Macy's
department store and he had work I mean
I can't tell you the whole story of the
book but this amazed me to find these
things out and I even met his friend
Nathan Straus his sons who still
remembered auto very well so in other
words Otto had a tremendous knowledge of
English and as a good educational
exercise he had the girls write their
letters in Dutch then he translated
and the girls rewrote the letters in
English so dear Juanita I did receive
your letter and want to answer you as
quick as possible Margot and myself are
the only children in our house our
grandma is living with us my father has
an office and mother is busy at home I
live not far from school and I am
sitting in the fifth class we have no
our classes we may do what we prefer of
course we met must get to a certain goal
your mother will certainly know this
system it is called montessori we have
little work at home that means homework
on the map I looked again and found the
name Burlington because Burlington is
near at Danville Iowa I did ask a
girlfriend of mine if she would like to
communicate with one of your friends she
wants to do it with a girl about my age
not with a boy I shall write her a dress
underneath did you yourself write the
letter I received from you or did your
mother do it I include a postcard from
Amsterdam and she'll continue to do that
collecting picture cards I have already
about 800 a child I used to be at school
with went in New York and she did write
a letter to our class some time ago in
case you and Betty get a photo do send a
copy as I am curious to know how you
look my birthday is the 12th of June
kindly let me know yours perhaps one of
your friends will write first to my
girlfriend for she also cannot write
English but her father or mother will
translate the letter hoping to hear from
you I remain your Dutch friend
annalisamurray Frank and on the side she
wrote old 11 years meaning that her
friend is 11 years old and this friend
is very important her name was Susannah
sauna for short Letterman and she's
important because she was one of Anne's
best friends and I came to get to know
her sister who survived over the phone
I'll tell you more about her later so
keep that name in mind because this book
was to be not only about Anne and Margot
but about many of the other children who
were their friends
this is the photo that and sent to
Juanita and this is the one that's
almost identical to the one that's on
the original cover of the English
language edition of the book that came
out in 1952 this is the post card she
sent its kind of faded here but it
really is a beautiful card and when you
see it in the book you'll see the rich
brown colors when I went to the Anne
Frank House I asked if they could
identify which canal it was but they
couldn't they said it just was truly
typical and loved collecting picture
postcards her favorites were movie stars
a girl after my own heart and British
and Dutch royal families now I just
thought I'd read the message that she
wrote on the card dear Juanita this
picture shows one of the many old canals
of Amsterdam but this is only one of the
old city there are also big canals and
over all those canals are bridges there
are about 340 bridges within the city
and Frank more bridges than there were
people in Danville at that time I just
realized this is the picture that Margot
sent with her letter if their father was
an amateur photographer and took many
pictures of them each year and they also
did those passport-size snapshots and I
think that was what these were I won't
read Margo's whole letter but I want to
read a portion of it because Margot
wrote a little about the political
climate of the time the letter by the
way the letters were written and sent
late april nineteen forty and just a few
weeks later the Nazis occupied the
netherlands and just a couple of weeks
before the Nazis had invaded Denmark and
Norway and there they the girls and the
Frank family were originally from
Germany they had gone to Amsterdam
thinking it would be safer there and
Otto Frank's family lived in Switzerland
so this is what Margot says we often
listen to the radio as times are very
exciting having a frontier with Germany
and being a small country we never feel
safe I only have two cousins a boy
living at basel switzerland and that is
buddy Elias who now heads up the Anne
Frank funds for American ideas this is
not far but for us it is we have to
travel through Germany which we cannot
do or through Belgium and France and in
that we cannot either it is war and no
visas are given this picture has never
before been published this is of an in
the background or i can use this
wonderful new toy i just got this is
working yes this is an and this is her
teacher Miss padrone and this is at
montessori school and this is about the
time that Anne was corresponding with
the girls in Iowa this is a picture of
an on her 10th birthday they lived in an
area called the mo wetta plane and
that's in South Amsterdam I don't know
if any of you have ever been to
Amsterdam I went to visit and it really
still looks the way new york city
streets very much the same so let me see
if i can get this to work i'll show you
am i doing this right
oh I was using the wrong thing this is
an second from left this is sana and
this is another friend Han illegal ER
who now lives in israel and i spoke to
her over the phone and you now kids are
girls you know how it is those three
were the best friends ana sauna and Hana
they were a trio it was a click let's
face it and no one else could break in
but these were all the friends who came
to the party and this was a very happy
time despite the fact that war was
looming now back to Iowa this is juanita
on the left and her sister Betty on the
right at about the same age as Juanita
is 10 in this picture and Betty is 14
and they kept waiting to hear from their
pen pals and they couldn't understand
why they weren't getting another answer
and their teacher Miss birdy it gave
them the news briefs because a town like
Danville didn't even have its own
newspaper and Miss birdy tried to bring
her intervention to the classroom and
she said since the Nazis had just
occupied the Netherlands the girls
probably couldn't send out any more
letters here are the girls you can see
my little label for the chapter when I
do the books I have to send all my
pictures back to New York and I identify
each and every one here it is chapter 3
22 you can see the date 1941 and this is
Betty and this is juanita with their
bikes on their farm I wanted to contrast
the safe place that our American girls
were in with Amsterdam at that time I
things were hard for the Wagner family
the girl's father had died from a
terrible accident when they were very
little and their mother had to take care
of them herself and she taught at this
one-room schoolhouse called possum
Hollow and I've never seen a one-room
schoolhouse so I thought this was an
important way to get across what Iowa
was like at that time
they also had farmers who rented their
farmland and contributed what they
earned to the Wagner family you'll see
in the book mrs. Wagner's whose name
also was and father and law was very
nasty and when his son died he refused
to help out these three women so they
had to go it alone they work very hard
here's a picture that betty was very
proud of this is betty driving the wagon
a tractor and i said what is that she
said hey you idiot you know because I
told you I come from New York I've never
seen a hay wagon so to me this really
captured what their farm was like and
how different it was from a city like
Amsterdam back to Amsterdam this is an
in 1941 I I bet many of you have seen
this picture at her desk she loved
montessori school it was a very good
choice for her and in my book I told
some about how her parents chose it for
her and she was her teacher that year
was mrs. Cooper is who was the head
principal of the school now her class
made Henny who I met and who showed me
around had a very different take on mrs.
Cooper asst but you know how it is
teachers and students we all have our
own personal opinions okay next this was
her friend sana Letterman and asana was
a beautiful girl she had also come from
Germany her father was a distinguished
lawyer and like the Frank family they
had fled to Amsterdam thinking they
would be safe there sana was the one who
wanted a penpal not a boy and saunas
sister Barbara was about a little bit
older than a Margo and when the Nazis
kept passing more and more laws in
making life more and more unbearable for
Jews Barbara joined the underground
resistance and became a resistance
fighter and she made it to the
state she was the only one of her family
to survive I'll tell you a little bit
more about her after the Nazis that year
in 1941 passed law after law they for
bad Jews from going to public swimming
pools they wouldn't allow Jews to attend
movie theaters or concerts Jews were not
allowed to go to public parks there were
laws and laws and laws and and who loved
getting a suntan would sit out on the
terrace of her parents apartment and
work on her tan on the terrace and she
wrote to her grandmother it's a pity but
that's how it is optimism and an upbeat
attitude was one of her great strengths
and like very much boys and romance she
was crazy about boys she had her first
major crush when she was 11 years old
and wrote about it in detail and she
there was nothing so exciting and seeing
a new bride and groom and this is an
amazing picture that's rarely been
published a couple had just gotten
married and maybe a member of the family
was taking a home movie and the
photographer happened to pan up and
caught a glimpse of and leaning over the
balcony of her apartment to look at the
new bride and groom down below and I
thought it was a wonderful picture and I
wanted it in this book here is another
picture that's never before been
published this is an on the left and her
friend sana on the right don't get my
pointer and this little boy was
misidentified when I found this picture
in an archive he was misidentified as
saunas brother and when I spoke to sana
sister Barbara who lives in North
Carolina she said oh no that was our
little cousin Raymond and the house in
the background belonged to their
relatives and you know how families do
then each girl could invite a friend and
sana invited and to go with her and it
was wonderful to include some excerpts
from Ann's letter about how the girls
enjoyed their vacation together Barbara
said that it was a very happy summer
this picture shows all the girls sitting
out in the woods this also has never
before been published let me see if I
can get this is Barbara this is sana
this is barbara's friend Tenakee I if
there's anyone dutch here forgive me for
mispronouncing everything and this is an
and you can just see it captures that
happy feeling that the girls had on
vacation and barbara said that was a
happy summer barbara made it here wound
up marrying a biochemist who was at the
university in north carolina and he won
a Nobel Prize and it was incredible to
look on the internet and to find her and
she worked with me very closely when I
did my text and and loaning me these
pictures so that I could get my
information correct and right it's very
easy to make mistakes when you're
writing about a time and a place and you
weren't an eyewitness and there's
nothing like having an eyewitness and it
was important to her to have these
pictures of her sister published finally
now back to Iowa this was a wonderful
summer for Juanita and for Betty even
though they had to do a lot of chores
they had a happy summer as you can see
from this picture of juanita on the farm
that summer the United States was not at
war but I guess government people knew
that war was coming and an a munitions
plant was built just outside of Danville
and meant a great upsurge in the
population of Danville in fact I think
Betty said her mother rented out some
rooms to borders all of a sudden the
town became a bustling town on December
7 1941 the Japanese bombed Pearl Harbor
and America entered world war 2 for me
this book was a way of looking at
history by seeing what happened in
Amsterdam what happened in the United
States seeing how the war impacted the
lives of these two sets of sisters in
Amsterdam the Nazis kept passing more
laws any Jewish person over the age of
six had to wear a yellow star with the
word Jew printed on it
Jewish children could not go to school
here's the yellow star Jewish children
could not go to school with non-jewish
children they had to go to separate
schools these two girls are going
attending a school similar to the one
and went to that year that year she
entered a Lyceum and she even wrote an
essay about it Elysium is a word for
high school and she spent the whole year
at this special Jewish school and at
first she thought she would not have any
friends but on her very first day she
became best friends with this young
woman named Jacqueline Jacqueline Van
Morrison Jackie and in her diary she
refers to Jacqueline by the name Hopi
j/o p IE I'm sure I'm not pronouncing it
right and I had the privilege of meeting
Jacqueline when I went to Amsterdam over
a year ago to research this book Jackie
wrote a wonderful book herself called my
friend Anne Frank the girls love to
spend time together they were best
friends for that whole year and they I
said what did you do together or they
started a ping pong club they slept over
at each others houses they did their
homework together they both love movie
stars and had collections of these
postcards with movie studio they traded
back and forth and they love to read
they were both very good students and
avid readers now this book was part of a
series kind of like Nancy Drew if any of
you have ever read Nancy Drew where the
Hardy Boys called I'll get this wrong
hoop two who'll and this young woman as
you can see by our outfit is a very
adventuresome kind of boyish type I
always remember Nancy Drew in her
roadster you know the Bronx we never
drove cars and I thought what is a
roadster whatever it is I want one so
this young woman was very adventuresome
and this particular book I picked up at
a secondhand bookstore and when I showed
it to Jackie she said oh that that's one
of the books we read and I promised I'd
send it to her and the translation of
this title is the high school years of
hoop to who
but she said their absolute favorite was
the one where they were hoop and her
friends meet the guys are going to marry
for her 13th birthday and received many
gifts her favorite was a gift she picked
out herself at a neighborhood stationery
store it was a diary with a plaid cover
and this was one of the special
cherished possessions she took with her
when her family hurriedly went into
hiding back in Iowa the United States
was at war and kids at Danville school
really hardly knew about current event
on those days there was no TV and even
radio I wrote in the book I was amazed
Betty and Juanita didn't even have a
radio for a long time they couldn't
afford it they finally had one when the
Japanese bombed Pearl Harbor but these
things were expensive and not easy to
come by so at school they would show
newsreels and I decided to have a clip
from one of these newsreels I won't even
tell you what I went through to get this
clip you don't want to know no but it
was worth it because I thought it was
the exact thing that they would have
seen and it kind of said the world at
war and this was how the kids at
Danville knew what was going on and miss
birdy kept up the news now I put in a
lot of information in the book about
what kids in Iowa did for the war effort
they collected scrap metal they grew
vegetables in Victory Gardens and there
was a slogan American five American
farmers are fighting the good fight the
idea was that American farmers
especially a state like Iowa where I
think ninety percent of the people work
on farms were growing food that would
mainly go to the Armed Services this is
a picture of juanita you can see she's
growing up she was around 12 years old
in this picture she had I trouble and
she had a drop out of school for a while
and became a wonderful typist because
Betty took typing at school and would
come home and with the mother scraped
together enough money to get a little
typewriter and Betty to
everything she knew about typing to
juanita and in that way 1e2 became an
excellent typist and didn't fall back
and miss birdy being miss birdy sent
over assignment you can bet on it so she
didn't fall back in her grades after the
sneak attack on Pearl Harbor many
Americans became fearful of persons with
Japanese ancestry and the President
signed an order giving the government
authority to evacuate more than 110,000
people of Japanese descent from their
homes and send them to an internment
camp like this one at manzanar
California and I felt this was an
important horrible moment in history to
include in this book meanwhile in
Amsterdam the Nazis were passing more
and more laws against the Jews Jews even
had to turn in their bicycles can you
imagine that finally otto Frank and this
is Otto had a spice company and the
company was in the building at an
address called 263 prinsengracht along a
canal and this was his staff of helpers
and they agreed to risk their lives and
protect the Franks while the Franks and
then other friends went into hiding this
lady's name is meep geese and she was
the main one who was the contact between
the Franks and the outside world meep is
still alive a very frail old lady she
lives in Amsterdam this is Beppe and
this is mr. Coogler and this is mr.
Kleinman and I wrote about all of them
in the book because these people truly
risk their lives by protecting and
feeding and taking care of the French
for the two years they were in hiding on
July sixth 1942 without telling the
girls where they were going Otto and his
wife Edith said to the kids pack up
we're leaving now and the kids didn't
even have a chance to say goodbye to any
of their friends they did it this way so
that no one would suspect what they were
doing they left hints that they were
really going to Switzerland
but they weren't they went into hiding
in this building this was the back of
mr. Franks office building 26 33
prinsengracht this was the room Anand
Margo's shared this photo was taken
right after the war because while they
were staying there they had to keep the
curtains concealed all the time the
windows had to be covered I I hope that
you will read the diary I hope you will
read the excerpts I included can you
imagine being cooped up a girl like Anne
who loved to go roller skating play
ping-pong be out with her friends they
had to be quiet all day long for an said
this was the hardest part for her in her
diary to be silent they couldn't use the
bathroom because they couldn't let any
of the workers down below other than
their staff know that they were hiding
there it's an incredible story and no
one can tell it better than and didn't
her own diary this is the room that Anne
and Margot shared if you visit the Anne
Frank House today the room is totally
empty the way it was after the Nazis
arrested them and cleaned out all their
stuff except for the pictures on the
wall Anne's father brought along her
postcard collection with these movie
stars and you can't it's hard to see but
when you see it in the book you'll see
it a little closer and I've named some
of these movie stars because many of
them are American stars Ginger Rogers
Ray Milland there were two sisters who
she especially was crazy about Priscilla
and rosemary lane this was even before
my time I gotta tell you but I went and
found a picture of these two sisters
because Anne wrote a story while she was
in hiding called dreams of Hollywood
stardom or dreams of film stardom and
she imagined a trip visiting these two
stars and she has a chance to become a
model and then she decides oh it's too
hard too exhausting and she gives it up
the room was recreated for a film that
was made a few years back and I thought
readers might enjoy seeing what it was
like this was the little desk where
anded her writing
and it's my belief that she missed her
friend so much this was so hard for her
that perhaps she turned to her diary as
for companionship in she kept pasting
pictures old pictures of herself hurt
she had brought along some photo albums
and alongside this picture of her that
it actually had been taken a couple of
years earlier she wrote this inscription
she said this is a photo as I wish as I
would wish myself to look all the time
then I would maybe have a chance to come
to Hollywood it was an stream to go to
Hollywood and that was another part of
my theme I wanted to stress her
connection her love of America the
Franks and the friends they were in
hiding with were arrested on the morning
of August fourth 1944 by this secret
policeman named Carl Joseph silber Bauer
he and some other members of the secret
police broke in and immediately went to
that secret bookcase that was the
concealing wall that hid the annex from
the rest of the building they and
usually kept her papers and not only
wrote in that diary but she expanded and
wrote in notebooks and on loose sheets
of paper some of these papers are now on
exhibit at the United States Memorial
Holocaust Museum in Washington DC when
the policeman looked for valuables he
took that briefcase and shook everything
out on the floor and he saw nothing of
value and they marched Anne and Margot
their parents and the other six Jews who
were hiding with them and they were
driven off to Nazi headquarters meep
went back afterward and gathered up the
papers and bands diary and locked them
in a drawer and said i will save these
for an when she comes back I'm sorry
this picture is so dim it shows up
better in the book it's a picture of the
next stop for the Frank family they went
to Westerbork transit camp
and these are the Nazi officers who were
putting people on and off the trains the
ironic tragedy of it is that from
Westerbork the Frank family went on the
very last train that was sent to a
schvitz if it had only been a day later
a week later they might not have been
sent we wanted to include a number of
maps so that readers could understand
the events and this particular map shows
Anne's route through Europe starting
with her birthplace in Frankfurt then
moving to Amsterdam when she was a
little girl then the Westerbork transit
camp then a schvitz with her mother and
father and sister and then the mother
and father were left behind at Auschwitz
and just Anne and Margot were sent on to
bergen-belsen and that's where they died
in March 1945 just a couple of weeks
before the British liberated the camp
the two girls died of typhoid typhus
about 600 children survived Auschwitz
and in this particular picture they're
showing their tattooed numbers on their
arms even the children were tattooed the
Russians liberated the camp Auschwitz
and we felt these pictures as terrible
as they are were important because news
of this these atrocities were with just
barely leaking out in the United States
people didn't know they didn't believe
that people just find it very hard to
believe such things had taken place and
as a dare always as a picture speaks a
thousand words after the war otto was
the only member of his immediate family
to survive he went back to Amsterdam the
recovery process as you can well imagine
was a long slow one especially when he
found out that his wife and daughters
had perished it was then that miggy's
said i will give you this diary this is
your daughter's legacy to you
and at first he couldn't even read it
and then when he started reading it he
couldn't put it down because he was
discovering the depth of his daughters
feelings of her thoughts the person she
really was he had absolutely no idea and
then he felt that he had to publish it
he this is a picture of Otto and Jackie
remember the friend Jacqueline van
marzin he looked up he especially wanted
to be with his daughters friends that
gave him the most comfort and he showed
the diary to Jackie and she couldn't
even read it at first she felt it was
too personal that maybe an wouldn't have
wanted anyone to read it so i do' had to
do a lot of soul-searching before he
finally thought this is what an would
have wanted she would have wanted it
published the book was first published
in dutch then it was published in
english in 1952 and as I'm sure many of
you know it became the most important
book about World War two and is still
considered the most important book it's
been translated I have the number in my
book I think 70 different languages I
checked with the Anne Frank House a
stage play was written based on the
diary and it became a subject of a lot
of controversy some people felt as the
the playwright's made it to upbeat to
entertaining 2-2 warm-hearted and I had
the honor and pleasure of getting
acquainted with the widow of Joseph
schildkraut Joseph schildkraut was the
actor who played auto on the stage and
in the movie this is Millie Perkins who
played an in the movie and leanora
schildkraut explained to me how a play
is a different sort of thing than a book
and how certain changes were made to
make the play gripping for the audience
and the play proved to be a very moving
piece of literature especially in
Germany people who couldn't bring
themselves to read the diary went to see
the play and this is terribly important
by the way just well you don't have to
go back
we're launching this book at the simon
wiesenthal center Museum of Tolerance
Sunday November 23rd I'm inviting you
all to come if you're willing to make
the drive it in the afternoon and Milly
Perkins has agreed to come and read from
my book which is a great honor to me and
very meaningful because she played the
part of an in the movie well meanwhile
the Wagner sisters as I told you had no
idea who their pen pals were and when
Betty heard the review of the play over
the radio as I told you she ran to the
bookstore saw the photo and said oh my
goodness this is our Anne Frank and so
now instead of keeping the pictures in
the shoebox she put them in the Flyleaf
of the book and it still SAT there
because a lot of people weren't that
interested and then she had a Jewish
friend who had dinner with her one
evening in 1988 and they were talking
about World War two and she brought out
these letters and the picture and he
started shaking she said he nearly
fainted and he said do you realize what
you have here this is a piece of history
and you have to share it with the world
so Betty said okay he took charge of
contacting the Swan galleries in New
York and they put the letters up for
auction and the sisters this is Betty
were flabbergasted by the attention this
created see am I getting this is Betty
holding the letters as you can see
global interests tons pen pals of Anne
Frank I think that's pretty much the way
it was she said that she couldn't even
take a shower that morning when the
press release came out News teams were
parked on her doorstep reporters were
calling every minute she kept a record
at every five minutes somebody would
call her up wanting an interview they
flew her to New York to enter you were
on TV there was she thought there might
be a little interest but she had no idea
there would be that degree of interest
and same is true for Juanita in fact
Linda said she thinks she might have
recognized Juanita as a patron of this
library this is juanita and this was
printed in the
redlands daily facts not your ordinary
pen pals and I thought we've got to have
this picture because that's for sure and
the sisters were amazed at the interest
generated by their letters by their
correspondence well the letters went up
for auction Whoopi Goldberg was one of
the participants who bid for the letters
but it wound up going to someone who
remains anonymous and when he came in
with the highest bid he then donated the
whole correspondence to the Simon
Wiesenthal Center museum of tolerance
and today there is an exhibit on
permanent display showing a facsimile of
the letters they keep the letters in the
vault in fact when we were preparing the
book and the color of the letters Adair
went to the vault to check on the colors
because this cheap writing paper ages
and you know the color changes and we
wanted to make sure what color it really
was but you can see the snapshots that
the girls sent and the picture postcard
it's a wonderful exhibit when this is
very curious to me when Juanita and
Betty realized who their pen pal was
they wrote a letter to their old teacher
Miss birdy and she wrote an entry in her
diary to the effective well this girl
who was their pen pal was the one who
was hiding in an addict I think I'll
have to read that diary it was
understatement if ever there was one for
me this was such an amazing experience
to find out more about World War two and
about what happened to Anne's friends I
wanted to know what had happened to
sauna she and her family were gassed
immediately at a schvitz it wasn't just
writing about an and wasn't just about
writing about Margot it was a thinking
of all these children who perished only
because they were Jewish and the beauty
of Juanita and Betty is that they were
not Jewish they had never known a Jewish
person they just picked a girl from two
girls from the Netherlands because I
thought it would be
to have a Dutch pen pals and I think
that's the way it should be I thought in
closing I would just read the last
portion of this book over the years and
has come to symbolize the 1.5 million
Jewish children who were murdered in the
Holocaust huge numbers of people tore
the Anne Frank House a large proportion
of them are American there have been
tributes to an from all over the world
streets have been named for her but the
lessons learned from her diary seemed to
have had a particularly strong impact on
America in Boise Idaho and Anne Frank
Human Rights memorial features a bronze
sculpture of an holding her diary as she
peeps out an imaginary window even in
Hollywood the place and so much wanted
to visit there is a little garden name
for her in the beth alam cemetery the
montessori school that she attended in
amsterdam is now called the anne frank
school and enlarged replica of her
signature is painted on the brick
building above the entrance inside a
plaque lyst the names of all the Jewish
children who were sent away from the
school in 1941 the names of the
concentration camps where they were
killed and the dates of their deaths and
Frank is just one of those 81 names but
through her diary stories and letters
she her friends and the other 1.5
million children who perished will
always be remembered and I wanted to end
this book with a quote from Anne's essay
called give that she wrote while in
hiding on March 26 1944 she wrote how
wonderful it is that no one has to wait
but can start right now to gradually
change the world and I hope that we all
can do that thank you so much for your
attention
Frankie
now we're going to open the program up
for questions and maybe I'll have
answers and anybody who has a question
would you be good enough to go to one of
these microphones on the side so
everybody can hear I hope there are some
questions any questions yes sir would
you come to the microphone please if you
don't mind oh thank you very much
where did they actually find the diary
at meep save the diary every and was
always writing writing writing and the
helpers you know the staff who took care
of the Franks not only brought food but
they would bring things like writing
paper because an quickly filled up that
whole diary it's on display at the end
frank house well this is what happened
she wrote in the diary then when she ran
out of space they brought her notebooks
then when she ran out of space they
brought her loose sheets of paper and
every night for safekeeping because she
was a girl and she didn't want anyone
reading her diary she would put it in
her father's briefcase for safekeeping
so that no one would take a peek at what
she was writing and sometimes they would
say and what are you writing and she
didn't want to tell anybody and when the
police arrested them they took autos
briefcase and shook it upside down and
out came all these papers and notebooks
and Diaries and the police thought oh
that's nothing but just a lot of junk
and when the police left with the Franks
meat went back in collected aunts diary
she knew it was Anne's writing and she
put it in a desk drawer and locked it
and she never read it and she wouldn't
let anyone else look at it she thought I
will save this for an she wrote a book
and this is how I know this is what she
did and I quoted a lot from her book and
when Otto came back after the war he
lived with meep and her husband he had
no place to go and they still were
hoping that the girls were okay they
found out that mrs. Frank had died at
Auschwitz but they were still hoping you
know people didn't find out right away
who was alive and who was not and when
they finally found out through the Red
Cross that Anne and Margot had died then
meep opened the drawer unlocked it and
gave auto the diary and said this is for
you this is your daughter's legacy and
he kept it and he kept it he said he'd
never let it out of his sight and it was
the most precious possession to him it
was all he had left Margot also had a
diary but they never
that she also wrote in a diary and today
the the diary was so important to him it
was more important than anything else he
dedicated the rest of his life to taking
care of that diary to getting it
published to overseeing you know the
rights to the movie all that the diary
never leaves Amsterdam there's an anne
frank house and there's an aunt Frank
foundation that her cousin buddy Elias
heads up in Basel Switzerland so right
now some of her notebooks and writings
are at the holocaust museum but the
diary never leaves and if you ever go to
the Anne Frank House you can see a thank
you for your question it's I'm sorry you
had to walk down yes miss would you go
to the microphone please well they asked
me to please have you do that won't you
please what was your question
okay and I know like in the room like
Anne and Margot they shared a room ready
right do they have a nightstand cuz it
could be in there because that's right I
would usually leave my stuff if I don't
know if i didn't i send that's right i
usually leave paperwork but you know if
they were in such cramped quarters and
this is what happened Anne and Margot
were roommates then another family came
along with their son Peter and they
lived in another room in that little
cramped hiding place it was a little
cramped area and then another person
came along a sixth person and he was a
dentist and an couldn't stand him and
she didn't trust him and then they
thought how should we do the rooms and
they decided that Margot was too old to
be a roommate with the dentist so they
had Margot sharing a room with her
parents and Anne's new roommate was this
dentist who she couldn't stand and she
didn't want to leave anything where he
could find it so she felt she trusted
her father and for whatever reason she
felt the safest place for her diary was
in her father's briefcase Samantha
having to do Margo's diary I don't know
it's a good question because scholars
would love to see what Marco wrote and
Margot was writing all the time she was
an excellent student gender do a
thorough search certainly they did a
thorough search but the Nazis had come
in and just taken everything and just so
anything that wasn't put away for safety
and that's why I told Frank after the
war said he wanted the rooms just the
way they were when the Nazis arrested
them and took everything they thought
was valuable even maybe an old
nightstand so you're right who knows
maybe it's in somebody's old nightstand
and it'll turn up that's a good question
thank you there any other questions yes
miss would you come and use the
microphone oh well oh good i have a
question it's not about and frank it's
more about you okay in this day and age
it's extremely unusual to have somebody
introduced as mrs. and i know you're not
doing this just casual
you must have given this some very
serious thought and it's just very
unusual my husband would be so happy if
he even offered to drive me that's so
nice of you to ask that well I don't
know I am married and I have four
children two step children three
grandchildren and Miz is you know how
you're usually introduced but I don't
know mrs. things more friendly it just
seemed I thought maybe there was some
reason I just thought its initial well
it is your way but thank you for
mentioning it I'll tell my husband
tonight if you still awake when i get
home which I seriously do yes oh and
this young girl too we will you remember
your question I was wondering how many
letters all together were exchanged and
what did the American girls did they
send a second letter when they didn't
hear from them how did they find out
thank you so much I i forgot to mention
that when they didn't hear back first of
all there may be another letter than an
road to juanita because when I went to
Iowa I went through all the school
newspapers you know the school put out
its own paper called the Danville Ian
and I went through the paper starting in
1939 to see if there were any clues and
sure enough there was a mention that
Juanita and another girl in her class
they were in fifth grade have heard from
their Dutch pen pals and I thought wait
a minute that's March so maybe there was
another letter that was lost that was
never found you know I wish I could have
met Juanita to verify I don't know but
after the war the girl the Wagner
sisters kept wondering you know they
heard the news they really cared and
they kept wondering what was happening
to the Franks I didn't even know the
Franks were Jewish but they just
wondered about their pen pals so they
wrote a letter to their pen pals when
the war was over and Otto received this
letter and in his memoir he wrote to his
mother how their letter brought tears to
his eyes he started weeping because he
knew his daughters were gone he wrote a
five-page letter back to Betty and
Juanita telling everything that had
happened I included in my book and I
forgot to mention
my presentation and sadly one Betty and
Juanita lost that letter along the way
that's why it's so miraculous that they
kept these other letters and postcards
in an old shoe box but the letter from
Otto they lost and that's how they
realized what had happened and you know
that was that and betty was a teacher at
that time she taught school for just one
year following in her mother's footsteps
and she nearly had a nervous breakdown
and she said not for me but she shared
that letter with her students and i
quoted what she said to her students in
my book that's very touching how this
was such a horrible war and we as
americans were relatively safe you know
here in the united states thank you for
reminding me thank you i can't wait to
read the whole book thank you I have two
questions and what led you by writing
this book well I was very interested to
see how it happened that Ann and her
sister correspondent with two girls in
Iowa when I first saw the correspondence
I thought who are these girls in Iowa
were they Jewish how did they happen to
know the Frank girls what led them to do
that and then I met one of the pen pals
Betty and then I thought well I thought
this is an idea for a book how I could
really look at what happened to kids in
America during the war and what was
happening two kids in Amsterdam for me
it was almost like a tale of two cities
a tale of two sets of sisters one on the
farm one in Amsterdam and because I was
a very little girl during that period I
wondered what happened and for me it
became a study in history a way of
looking at history not with big numbers
and troops and all that stuff but
through individual people to me that's a
much more meaningful interesting way to
find out what happened and then my next
question is like I don't know if you
could answer this question but why were
they called concentration camps that's a
wonderful question I wish it dare were
here she would tell you maybe because
they
isn't rated people together they
clustered them that is such a good
question I'm going to ask it there will
you come to our launch and ask that hurt
yourself it's going to be at the Museum
of Tolerance in Los Angeles because the
Dare is an expert at that museum she
heads up the library and she would be
just the one to answer that if you even
want to write your name or I'll give you
her email address oh I think that's an
excellent question one of us has to
figure out a good answer for you there
are any other questions yes would you
come to one of the microphones
um when you were learning about and
Frank like in any special way did it
change your life that's a wonderful
question it did change my life I thought
this so easily could have been me and I
thought what I have had the courage what
I have had the good spirit to write to
make the best of things you know when
you read her diary she had such a sense
of fun and finding pleasure wherever she
could she would gaze out the window at
that chestnut tree she would fool around
and she would do skits and dress up to
get a laugh with the others I really
thought long and hard about it and i had
read the diary when i was your age and I
saw the play when it first came on
Broadway as a teenager but I went back
now and read the diary and it made me
appreciate our freedom so much more it
made me appreciate the freedom to be
Jewish and to be a writer so that it did
change my life very profoundly it's a
wonderful question she's truly is
someone to look up to I can see why
she's been considered what is called an
icon somebody that people look up to and
she's a wonderful writer and as a writer
when I would read the way she observed
details and used her words I thought oh
golly this is a high standard of
excellence do you have another question
thank you very much yes I'd like to know
what other projects you're involved in
and if you have something else you're
working on right now oh that's a lovely
question you'll make me nervous i'll
have to run right home and go back to
work well I have another I told you one
of the areas of interest is art and I
have another book coming out in March
with another publisher Random House
called art against the odds and then the
subtitle is from slave quilts to prison
paintings and our idea here was to
present art created by children and
adults most of whom never had any art
lessons or training
under situations of extreme hardship
because we believe that people human
beings really need an art as a way of
staying alive of having hope wanting
beauty in their lives and I work with a
wonderful editor who gave me the choice
of she said you just see who you want to
include and we'll go from there and I
had a hard time narrowing down the list
we included art by outsider artists
these are two people who were
schizophrenics mentally insane who did
the most phenomenal art that's and
museums are done by slaves who made
quilts that are gorgeous they were also
used on the Underground Railroad as a
secret code to help runaway slaves
escape knocked me out I never knew about
this we used art made by prisoners in
jails some of whom are still in jail and
gave us permission to use their art art
done by children one of the I did a book
called fireflies in the dark the story
of friedl decor Brandeis and the
children of terracing about a
concentration camp camp near Prague
during the war where this incredible
artist and teacher work with the
children to make art thinking it would
help sustain them and give them hope one
of the survivors of that terrible place
did not work with friedl but made her
own drawings and they were recently
published in a book called draw what you
see she lives in the Czech Republic and
I called her up and I said can we use
some of your drawings in the book so
it's going to have a wide variety of art
then then I'm working on a book on the
history of Jews in America called 350
years of Jews in America and that's a
tough task because I wanted to be
entertaining and not put students to
sleep and it's very hard for me to learn
all that history and put it all together
and I'm going to do a companion book to
fireflies in the dark about one
particular woman who survived
terrorizing her name is Ella wiesberger
and she sang she survived by singing and
there was a children's opera that was
performed 55 times at that place
currently and the Nazis kind of turned
away and let the Jews do this and the
Opera was called Brenda bar and she
always played the part of the bird and
it's a wonderful story of survival and
she's a marvelous lady and has agreed to
let me tell her story so those are a few
of the things I'm working on thank you
for asking any other questions oh go
ahead as a former Middle School on now
high school English teacher I do
appreciate your efforts because we need
all the good literature we can get thank
you my question is do you ever visit
schools oh yes I would love to visit
schools it's marvelous to meet the
students and teachers who hopefully read
the books I write you know how do you
know I'm sitting at home I don't know if
anybody's reading them and how wonderful
to come out in an evening like this and
meet so many of you who are interested
it means the world to me and I think
students enjoy meeting people who do
what I do I love research so I love to
tell about some of my research methods
and the whole it's like a treasure hunt
you know going from clue the clue so
I'll be glad to give you my card you can
send for me and it means a day that I
won't be all in my messy office but you
know I really do love coming out and
it's helpful to hear what the students
have to say it often really informs my
work question you mentioned in the
lecture about the the German Nazi he
went in and immediately went to the
bookshelf and found the hiding place do
they ever find out who not knocked him
off oh what a wonderful question first
of all he was a member of the green
police the secret police so that's an
important distinction recently you know
they're still trying to figure out who
it was and as I was writing this book
they thought they had found the man
because he went directly to that
bookcase so they were sure that any you
know meep and the others watched in
horror and there was nothing they could
do and they knew somebody must have
tipped him off and there were a lot of
moments during those two years that an
writes about in her diary when and if
you see the movie the movie version
where somebody broke in there was a
robber there were many opportunities
for somebody to find out well just when
I was working on this book they thought
they'd finally discovered the identity
that it was a man named tani dollars who
is a Nazi sympathizer but they did a lot
of research and the case came up and was
investigated and they could never
conclusively prove it and when I went to
the Anne Frank House I said how shall I
handle this and they said you must say
that the case is still open and it was
Simon Wiesenthal himself who tracked
down Carl Joseph silver bearer I
included that anecdote in my book I
thought it was so interesting it not
interesting it was important the play
was put on in Germany and some kids who
were I guess pro-nazi came up and said
to reason though well how do we know
this really happen you never found out
who arrested them how do we know and
they challenged him and he said I'm
going to find who arrested the Franks
and he did it was an exhaustive search
so that picture comes from the file of
the Simon Wiesenthal file that picture
of that policeman but they never knew
for sure and when they thought they had
found him it was front-page news in the
Netherlands because I've been
corresponding by email with the author
of a biography of Anne Frank and she
wrote a book about otto Frank and we
correspondent about this and I have some
young married friends who live in
Netherlands and they told me it was
front-page news you know like our
sensational news items it was on TV all
the time day and night so maybe they'll
someday find out who the betrayer was
that's a good question Joe thank you
look I have two questions and one of
them is the Anne Frank House was that
the one turned into a museum or did they
build like a little house and then put
the items in it no that's a good
question the actual place where the
family hid for two years is now a museum
and mr. Frank said he didn't want
anything changed know those pictures on
the wall those postcards from Anne's
collection they're still there I think
they have a glass covering to protect
them but it's exactly the way it was the
day they left and he wanted to kept just
that way now in addition they've added a
Study Center and a bookshop you know
places where students can go and look at
books look at books about Anne Frank
about other historical matters but the
actual hiding place is kept just the way
it was and you walk up the little narrow
staircase just the way the Franks did
it's an amazing experience I hope you
get to go there someday do you have
another question my second question was
that it's it that there was a bookshelf
and it swung open it was the doorway how
did the Nazis find that that's exactly
what Joe is saying they are sure that
somebody betrayed the Franks somebody
knew that that secret bookcase you know
was like a secret door that opened
because when the police came in they
didn't kind of roam around they went
right for that bookcase that was that
concealed the annex where they were
hiding and to this day they've never
found out who it was who knew who tipped
off the Nazi police do you know that
rewards were given money rewards were
given for any Jews that were captured so
maybe somebody turned in the Franks for
a money reward it's a kind of horrible
thing but that might have happened but
nobody knows for sure some other
questions well again I want to thank you
so so much for being a wonderful
audience and so responsive and I look
forward to seeing you
and I hope that you read this book and
other books and if you haven't read the
diary and if you haven't read the play
and the revision of the play I hope
you'll go back and read it because there
are no words like the words of Anne
Frank thank you again Susan Goldman
rubens books searching for Anne Frank
letters from Amsterdam to Iowa is
published by Abrams books for young
readers visit them on the web at abrams
books com